えーでは時間もなくなりましたので始まります
あの まあ自殺 何でしたっけ？自殺
その仏教心理学 まあちょっと心理学的な
まあそんな大胆なことはしませんよ
すごい難しい かなり仏教心理学といえばね
はい いきます  全ての生命に自殺願望が必ず存在すると
悟らない限りヴィバワータンナー非存在の活罪になります
だからまあそれだけ覚えておけば
全ての生命にあります
自殺願望は ヨーロッパの考え方とこちらの仏教の考え方が違うところはそこらなんですよ
ヨーロッパ思考で見れば
一部の人間に突然現れるのであって
それからヨーロッパでは自殺っていうのはヨーロッパではなくて
この西洋宗教ではもう全くも許せない罪でしょうし
特にイスラム教でも自殺っていうのはもう最悪の罪なんです
もうとんでもない罪です
仏教でいう親殺しみたいなもんなんです
でもやってますけどね
で キリスト教の場合でも同じように考えているので
だからそういう方々は別にこの明確に人間の心を勉強したわけじゃなくて
ただそう ある日突然起こる異常現象だと思うんです
仏教はそうじゃなくて
自殺願望はみんなにあるんだよと
全ての生命に だから気をつけなくちゃいけないんです
一人一人みんな とんでもないやつを心の中にいるんだから
とんでもない危険なものがね
かつ何でしたっけ？ヴィパッサナーがあるんだから
一人一人の人が気をつけないと
これはもう発作をする可能性あります
無常の法則  それで無常の法則で喋ります
人は必ず死ぬから その時期になったら
己に対する未練を捨てて死を歓迎するのに期待するようになる
それで私たちにはまだまだ自殺願望ないと思うかもしれませんだけど
全て無常だから我々必ずしも死ぬでしょ
そこで死がどんどん近寄ってくると
ヴィパッサナー機能するんですよ
もうカーマタンナーできんだからね
病院でもう縛られているんだからね
鼻に管入れて 手に管入れて
もういろいろでしょ まあ誰かとふざけて遊びたいとかそんなとこじゃないです
だからカーマタンナーは機能しない
もうどうしても死ぬんだから
死にたくないというババタンナーももう機能しない
残るのヴィバワータンナーですよ
いわゆる非存在欲がその時機能します
ではどういうふうに機能しますかというと
なんとなく死を期待するんですよ
はい  死を迎えるとほとんどの人は
大体この皆様も大体親しい人々のね
最期を見届けたことはあると思いますけど
ほとんどの場合 みんな落ち着いて死ぬんですよ
若い時はもう乱暴者で
わがままで もう仕事の鬼でとか
何かあってもなんとなく死ぬどころになってくると
穏やかで もうすごい穏やかで死ぬんでしょ
あれがヴィパッサナー機能するんです
もういいやと思う 死にますと
だから世間のことについては何も未練がないんですよ
だからあなたはしっかり会社なんとかして
そういうふうな息子にも言えること言えないんですね
まあまあいいや もうみんな頑張ってっていうか
もう関係ないということで穏やかにいる
それがヴィパッサナー機能するんです
はい  病が不治だとすると
食事も延命措置も  それもありますね
時々もう癌で もうどうしようもない
もう治らないと言っちゃうと
混乱する人もいるんですけど
まあ１日２日はショックなんですけど
それからえらく穏やかになるでしょうに
もう死ぬんだとわかっちゃうと
だから死を受け入れる
死こそ私のものやと思っちゃうんです
それ自殺と同じなんです
その時すごい穏やかになるんです
頭が悪い自殺者とはちょっと違うんですけど
なぜかというと この無常の法則で必ずしももう体験しなくちゃいけない経験でしょ
死ぬということは その時はそうなるんです
大体この最後に病気に倒れると
もう食事なんか拒否する
いりませんと 別に怒っているわけでもないんだけど
もういいと 食べられませんと
時々この点滴で栄養を入れても体が拒否するんです
それで医者はもうもう何やってももうダメですと
受け入れませんと この体はと言うんですよ
それは精神的にも自分がもう自殺願望になってるんです
自殺願望で言えばかっこ悪いんですけど
やっぱりもう死を迎える気持ちになっているんです
だから細胞さえも強引に栄養を入れても受け取らない
肉体が壊れていくと捨てたくなる
それからどんな人でも肉体がどんどん壊れていくと
これではもうもうもたないんだと
もう捨てましょうと 車が壊れたと同じなんですよ
車が壊れたらもう捨てましょうって気分になるでしょうね
あー惜しい いい車でしたとか
すごい愛情を持ってもうあった車でしょう
そんなのあれこれ全部なくなっちゃうんですよ
例えばもう 1週間ごとに車をちゃんとワックスかけたりして
またほこりをたたいたりして
男たちっていうのは車すごい好きですからね
で まあ子供たちにも遊ばせないでとかね
で いたっても事故っちゃって潰れちゃうと平気で捨てるんでしょ
だから我々のどんな人間でも体が壊れるんだから
その時は捨てる気にはなります
はい  これは自然の流れです
欲愛の代わりに存在欲が働く
だからカーマタンナ 食べたい
遊びたいということがなくなっちゃって
もうできんだからね その代わりにヴィパッサナー非存在欲が機能するんです
死を認めない人は存在欲で混乱する
怒り入れしまう  時々いますね
もうなんで私はがんになったんでしょうか？と
ものすごい不幸なんですよ
死ぬとこでも混乱するわ
もう叫ぶは怒鳴るは もうあれが死を認めたくないんです
どうしても死ぬのに ものすごい混乱して
もうもうとんでもない状態になるんです
穏やかには死にません
だからちゃんと自殺願望の欲が機能すると
穏やかで美しく死ぬんです
そのヴィパッサナーで
はい ヴィパッサナー機能しないとそんなことになります
この死に方では来世は
そういう人は来世はもう決まって不幸ですよ
混乱して死にたくない
なんだこれって なんで私に限ってこんなに気をつけて健康でいたのに
健康を守るために頑張ったのに
病気になったんでしょうかと
医者ももう信頼できませんとかね
こういう調子になると
もうヴィパッサナーは認めないんですね
まだまだ未熟で カーマタンハで生きていようとするんです
カーマタンハっていうのは
大体中年ぐらいになってくると控えた方がいいんですよ
遊びたいというのは これ若者の世界でね
もうカーマタンハはどんどん年取るとカーマタンハ控えて
ヴィパッサナータンハがあって
それも控えて 最後にヴィパッサナーという渇愛で死ぬっていうのは普通な流れなんです
はい  存在欲で落ち着く人は楽に死んで
法にふさわしいところに生まれる
だから あのヴィパッサナーが働く人が
1番目の欲もなくなって
2番目の欲も機能しなくなるんじゃなくて
機能しない状態に停止状態になって
最後に3番目のヴィパッサナー非存在欲が機能出す
それで 精神で落ち着く
もう捨てるんだから 体ともう世界も
で 楽に死ぬ 穏やかに死ぬ
死んで自分のもう今までの人生で行った業にふさわしい再生をするんです
はい  落ち着いて穏やかに死んだからといって
もう成仏できたか 天国に入ったかは分かって再生はどうなってきて
だから うちのおばあちゃまが大変穏やかで死んだんだからよかったと勝手に思っても
だからといって再生が再び生まれが素晴らしいということではわからないんですよ
で 次に生まれ変わる場合は
今まで自分が行った業が機能しますから
例えばものすごい悪いことをしていた人でも
死ぬ時は穏やかに死ぬ可能性はありますよ
でも次はあの業が機能する可能性はあります
はい それから別なテーマ
仙人の自殺どうでしょうかと
理性人の自殺は 今まで説明してきたのはこの俗人のこと
はい  俗世間の自殺は怒りですが
怒りが問題はない自殺もある
あり得る 世間の自殺っていうのは全部怒り
極端な怒り 病気 もう負け犬と負け犬の負け犬でしょ
自己破壊にも失敗するんだから
で 他の方法もあり得るんだと
肉体を持って生きることは
罪を犯しながら苦を味わって生きることだとし
肉体を持つことだけが絶対に避けたい
これが理解するんですよ
理性人が で なぜかというと
この肉体あることで罪ばっかしなんですよ
食べるために動物を殺さなくちゃいけないし
仕事をするために嘘を言わなくちゃいけないし
人はいじめなくちゃいけないし
搾取しなくちゃいけないし
もう生きること 自然破壊しなくちゃいけないし
みんなに迷惑をかけなきゃいけないし
もう一つもいいことないんですよ
肉体のせいで で 我々はしょうがないと
もう放っておいた 放っておきますけど
ものすごい敏感な理性人が
私が 1日生きるということはどれくらい他の生命に迷惑かと
私は 1日どれぐらい罪を犯しているんでしょうかと
そういうことを真面目に考えるんです
だから 1 日生きるということは
ものすごい罪を犯してるんですよ
あの小さな魚 なんて言いますか
これぐらい小さいやついるでしょ
あのじゃなくて食べる魚
白魚とかね あれはちょっと１０グラム食べても何匹ですかね
だから私たちの一食にもならんですけど
その命 生命が命を絶ちちゃったんですよ
だからもう生きるということはそう考えちゃうと
もう敏感な人だったらもう 1 日も生きていられなくなるんです
それで これが肉体のせいだと
別に心に食べさせてないでしょ
白魚が 肉体に食べさせてたんだから
ニワトリももう焼いてもうフライドチキンにして心に食べさせることはないでしょうに
心に何か栄養を与える
本ぐらい読めば別に本読んだっても何の罪もないでしょ
だから肉体っていうのはもう悪の塊で見るんですよ
だから絶対肉体だけは嫌と思っちゃうんです
その人は心の怖さにも
でも心も僕は心も怖いんだよと言うんですよ
全て心ですからね その人
それ知らん ただ体のことだけに気づくんです
はい  心のみの存在を目指して修行して無色界の禅定
を得る そういう人々はもう 1 日でも生きて生きてきたくないと思って出家したり
森に入ったりして 葉っぱやら落ちた木の実とかなんとか食べて
肉体だけは絶対嫌やと期待して必死で修行する
時々何も食べないで修行する
それで集中力が生まれたらサマーディ禅定状態ができて
どんどんどんどん広げていって
完全に肉体の関係切って切っちゃうんです
それは仏教専門用語で無色界というんです
それすごい高いレベルの瞑想なんです
それで心だけの生まれ変わりをするんです
だから心には空間は要りません
心っていうのはものじゃないんだから
置く場所は要りません
だから生まれ変わってるんですけど
場所はないんです 境地だけ
だから連絡できない お釈迦様にもできない
だからお釈迦様の先生二人が無色界の禅定あったんですよ
お釈迦様は悟り前に瞑想を教えてくれた先生二人が
アーラーラーカーラもウッダカーラもというんです
だからお釈迦様が悟ってから
私の先生二人も本当に解脱はできなかったと
これが自殺やと教えてあげたいなと思ったんですよ
先生ならすぐわかるんだそうと
で チェックしたらもう亡くなって無色界にいる
ああ 失敗しましたと 先生が損しましたと
もうコミュニケーションできない
ということで  伝統的なヴィパッサナーを以上のように
今 私は前のスライドで説明したのは
この伝統的な仏教のヴィパッサナーの説明なんですね
何か自殺願望は出てこないでしょ
でも肉体を捨てることが結局自殺的なんですよ
だから この俗世間での負け犬の方々の自殺とは比べて
これはもうすごいレベルの高い理性的なことだからね
でも自殺は自殺なんですね
はい  説明はしないが 皆にある問題
でもヴィパッサナーはみんなにあると仏教は認めています
説明はしないということは
注釈書などでは説明ない
今 私はずっとした説明は全くもないんです
仏教の注釈書なんかでは
私は経典の中からブッダの教えから
今日朝もう9時半で全部作っちゃったんですけど
ないんです 普通は だからこの英語では仏教の本たくさんありますけど
今日のテーマに扱ったところはどこにも誰も書いてない
肉体を持って生きることは嫌がるから
これは立派な自殺願望です
しかし 負け犬でもないし
不善思考がまずいというわけでもありません
これは善行  ですから この理性人が肉体は完全に嫌がることが不善じゃないんですよ
罪を犯してこないんです
人と喧嘩してまで商売するのかと
それまで生きることは大事なのかと
これ肉体のためでしょうと
不倫するにも もうもう子供家族を捨てる
他の女の人を追っていくのも
ものすごい人を不幸にするでしょ
肉体のためでしょ ここまで人間来る罪を犯すのかということだから
ものすごい善行為したいんですから
立派なんですね だから負け犬じゃないんです
彼らが勇者のように俗世間捨てて森に入るんです
私一人だけでも勝ちてみますよと
だから自殺願望は自殺願望なんですけど
不善ではない 悪ではない
すごい立派な善行為なんです
はい そこでゴーディカという大阿羅漢の物語は仏教の経典にあるんです
この聖人は自殺した  これは自殺したんですよ
このゴーディカ大阿羅漢は
落ち着かない性格で瞑想は
この初めは性格的に落ち着かないんですよ
子供みたい ちょっともう 1分
2分いるともう別なことしたくなるんです
それで瞑想 ですよ でもなんとか瞑想は進むんだけど
もう落ち着かないんだから
もうまた壊れちゃうんです
出家したのに悟らないこと
仏道を成功することができないことを
それで恥じたんですよ
私は出家したのに成功しないと何でダメでしょうかと
やったこと何でも成功するのはもう勇気のある人の道だからね
やるならば成功させるぞっていうのは
だからそのゴーディカ大長老も大やらかんも
もうせっかく出家したんだから成功したいんだと
で 悟りたいんだと で これが自分のこんなだらしない性格ではっていうことで
すごく恥を感じたんですね
はい  負けたくは 負けたくはないから
心が清らかな命を絶ちたい
それで負けたくはない
罪に負けたくはない 煩悩に負けたくはない
だから心を清らかにした瞬間で自殺してやるぞと思ったんです
命なんかどうでもいいやと
清らかな心の方が立派やと
それで自殺を決めたんです
はい  首を切って死んでいく間で無常を観察して大
それで首を切っちゃったんですよ
カミソリで切っても瞬時に死にませんだからね
どんどんもう死にかけていくでしょ
血が流れて その時間でも頑張らなくちゃと
このほんのわずかな時間で
また自分が今までの修行とどれほど真面目に仏道を頑張ったかとってことと
また無常観察するんですよ
みんな死にますよと で
私は別に怒りで死ぬわけじゃない
立派な人として この精神状態を保ちたく死ぬんだよということを観察すると
もう悟ったんですよ 大やらかに
最高たるゴールに達するための手段にしたので
この行為は釈尊が認められた
釈尊が全然なんであの人が自殺したのかと言わなかったんです
ゴーディカは立派ですと言ったんです
ゴーディカは成功しました
すごく褒めたんです はい
人はより優れたものを得るために価値ある小さなものを犠牲にする
そんなのを我々もやってますよ
より大きなものを目指すと
小さな小さなことはまあ捨てたぶでしょうに
例えば自分にお金があっていい家を建てられるんだと
まあ今部屋 2つしかない小さなボロ家に住んでるんだったら
平気でそれ壊すでしょうに
壊しましょうと 壊してそちらにいい家を建てる
ですから 大きなものを目指すと
小さなものは犠牲にしなくちゃいけないんです
だから それが別に負け犬の生き方じゃないんです
しっかりした人の生き方なんです
はい  自殺は罪  まあ実際自殺は罪ですかと
まあ読み上げるだけで十分だと思います
無料で死ぬからお金もかけて殺しになることは無知なことです
だから確実に無料で死ぬんだからね
お金かけてロープ買ったってもお金でしょ
たった 100円でもね
100円切符で買っても
もうバカな行為なんです
自殺は だって何も得られないでしょ
ゴーディカ大長老みたいにもう悟りのために死んだわけじゃないでしょうに
ただそんだけ また極端な怒り
はい 次に行きます  自殺自体は死ぬことに対して大したことではありません
死ぬっていうことは大したことじゃないんですよ
誰でも死ぬんだからね
何のこともないんです
どうせ死ななくちゃいけないし
大胆なことじゃないんです
はい  しかし 極端な怒りでないと自殺できない
しかし 自殺する人は極端な怒りで死ぬ
私たちは車にぶつけてとかね
階段転がってとか 頭打ってとかね
死ぬかもしれませんだけど
それは怒りでもなんでもないでしょうし
でも自殺者は極端な怒りで自殺するんです
はい  極端な怒りは大罪なの
これが大罪ですよ 極端な怒りが死んだことじゃないんです
だから死ぬ前でもすごい罪を犯してるんですよ
首を吊ると その前にもものすごく強烈な罪の流れ
これも何年も続けて考えてやっているんだから
もう見込みはない 将来的にも
死んだことは別にもう何のこともない
そんなのははい  他人を悲しませる
それでまた死ぬ時の目的というのは
私が死んで他人を悲しませてやるぞとかね
親を悲しませてそうか思って子供は自殺したりもするでしょ
汚いやり方なんですよ
でも自分が損するだけ
金死んだってもすぐに後で時間たつとなくなるしね
はい  他人を罪の意識で悩ませてやるという衝動で自殺
また このいじめられた時なんかは自殺する子どもたちとかね
もう名前 あの人 あの人
あの人にいじめられたとかね
ノート書いたり自殺するでしょ
だからこの仕返ししてるんですよ
そのいじめた人々に その目的です
バカでしょうに 仕返し
その子どもたちでもそんな気持ちはなかったそうと思ったら
それで終わりでしょうし
だからあまりも恐ろしいんですよ
この自殺者の気持ちは
はい  恐ろしい怒り  それは恐ろしい怒りです
うん 早く早く言って  何でもかんでも嫌になって自殺する
無知と弱気と怠惰  時々もう何でもかんでも人生嫌になっちゃって自殺する人もいますでしょ
その場合は無知と弱気で死ぬんですね
はい  借金を返す 家族を養うために保険金を目指して自殺をする
時々ね まあ借金があって払えないんですけど
自分の保険金もあります
で それだったら払える
それで自分が死んじゃうという自殺もありますね
あるいは家族には問題あって
お金がない それだって自分が自殺したら
もうその保険金でなんとかなるでしょうと
なんとなくなんかかっこよくそうに見えるんですけど
これは無知と激しい欲と怒りが絡んでるんですね
いいことじゃないんです
まず 借金やらお金問題を作ったことも欲がありすぎ
だからお金のトラブルを起こすんですよ
欲があると金が入らないんですよ
欲が無欲でないと そこら辺も失敗
無知でしょうし それから自殺することは激しい怒り
自殺するんです はい  自殺は
そういうことで自殺っていうのは罪なんです
死ぬこと自体はどうったことない
どうしても死ぬんだからね
その以前のこのプロセスがすごい罪なんです
はい  自殺は詳細ですが
追い込まれた感情によって罪は大中小になる
うん その追い込まれた感情によって
大罪か中罪か小罪かと決めなくちゃいけないんです
はい  ブッダの教えを極めた人でない限り
罪にならない自殺はできません
うん 慈悲の実践をすると
罪になる 自殺願望が消えて人生が平穏
だから自殺感 単純に怒りですから
慈悲の瞑想をすると穏やかに生きていられますよ
ブッダの教えを極めた人でない限りは
正しく罪にならない自殺はできません
だからもうもう 1億人に一人もいるかってわからないんです
だから一般的な自殺は罪になる
でも他宗教で言っているように
自殺自体が許されない罪って
そんなのは嘘ですけどね
もうただもう地獄に落ちるだけで
そこでまた立ち上がれるし
それから衝動のエネルギーによって大罪になったり
になったりもしますから
それはバラバラ どうったことはない
でも我々は怒りに悩むんじゃなくて
慈悲を実践すればみんな協力してくれるでしょうに
いじめ 学校でいじめられたっても
これで自分も一緒にやってね
喜んじゃえば 単純に仲間になっちゃうんです
だからこの慈悲だけあればもう怒りが消えてしまう
それで生きることっていうのはすごく楽になるんですよ
みんな協力する 人の協力を得ると
自分の心っていうのはものすごい力を発揮するんですよ
だから人間っていうのは頑張ってくださいと一言葉言われても
すごい気分いいでしょうね 「
ああ よく頑張ってるね」とか
一言でもよく精神的な支えでしょ
だから慈悲ですよ 答えは
慈悲さえあれば もうそういう精神的な追い込まれている人々の問題は解決する
はい そこら辺で終わります
はい 話はそこで終了いたします
はい